all right let's talk a little bit about
the shifting dynamics of the 2024
Republican primary number of interesting
things happening over the last 48 hours
first and foremost failed former
president Donald Trump's very uh I would
call it an increasingly unhealthy
obsession with Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis seems to be
getting worse and worse and worse Trump
completely out of control obsessed with
Ron DeSantis posting endlessly to truth
social about him sometimes multiple
times per hour now I pulled a bunch of
truths
um from a 24-hour period uh since then
Trump has continued posting so like I
could give you 10 more of these but I'm
not going to do that to you but just to
give you a sense of how obsessed Trump
is with a guy who as of right now isn't
even running against him and who by all
reasonable assessments can't even beat
Trump I mean Trump's already over 50
percent in most Republican primary polls
DeSantis is in the low 20s with a
campaign that seems to be slowing down
big donors abandoning DeSantis before he
even announces okay so it's like not
even really clear DeSantis is a major
threat to Trump regardless look at this
Trump going after DeSantis for coveted
death numbers by the way pretty unfair
because you really should go by rates
Trump just posting a chart of coveted
deaths but it's like Florida has a huge
population so it would make more sense
to look at Cova death rates regardless
he says so explain why did Ron Des
Sanctus do a good job highly overrated
New York had fewer coveted cases now New
York is better than Florida for a while
Florida was better than New York no new
tricks just the per capita confusion
that we've always been seeing Trump
continuing Des sanctimonious had nothing
to do with Israel or the moving of the
U.S embassy to Jerusalem never so much
has mentioned it to me it was the last
thing on his mind to Sanctus wasn't even
Governor yet it was December of 2017 and
I barely knew him he has turned out to
be a total flame out this is the kind of
disinformation I thought only the
Democrats would put out no wonder de
Sanctus is dropping like a rock in the
polls terrible
Trump continuing and remember this guy's
not running yet and he's also doing
terribly in the polls but Trump is just
obsessed collapsing at home DeSantis
travels to Israel and proclaims he moved
U.S embassy to Jerusalem not Trump but
it doesn't stop there again guys this is
like all within a few hours the
sanctimonious had a failed campaign when
he was running for governor he was ready
to drop out was way behind then I
capital E endorsed him it wasn't a
lowercase e endorsement it was a capital
E endorsement and he went big league but
artificially up the real de Sanctus
however is the guy we are all watching
crash a burn a really bad politician
enjoy the trip Ron Trump then retrothing
a guy named John Rich saying quote I
don't understand the logic of DeSantis
running let's just say he beat Trump in
the primary which won't happen but let's
hypothesize if he won there wouldn't be
one true Trump supporter left that would
vote for him and he would be destroyed
in a general election this is a losing
proposition no matter how you look at it
so why on Earth would he voluntarily run
head-on into the wood chipper now this
one is interesting for two different
reasons
Trump and failed Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake have both been
pushing this idea if DeSantis somehow
won the Primary
no Republicans would vote for him in the
general this is starting to be
an an odor of
maybe boycott the general if Trump
doesn't win the nomination which I
absolutely love the best scenario for
Democrats would be for Trump to lose the
primary and then for Republicans to
either stay home in protest or to write
Trump in or even better for Trump to run
third party and take 10 15 percent of
that vote those would be absolutely
dream scenario so that's an interesting
thing that Trump is now starting to
signal boost the idea of Republicans
wouldn't vote for DeSantis in the
general they wouldn't Kerry lake is
starting to signal boost that idea
that's number one number two that's
interesting about this is the idea of
really seeming to try to push DeSantis
not to even run it seemed at one point
that Trump was maybe looking forward to
the idea of a contested and heated
primary but now that Trump's talking
about I might not even debate
now that Trump's talking about maybe
DeSantis shouldn't even run it seems
that the tide has turned a little bit
and and the idea here is to prevent
DeSantis even from announcing okay Trump
continuing on Truth weirdly going after
Kaylee mcinanny his own former press
secretary saying quote I guess Kaylee is
no longer speaking so favorably about
Des sanctimonious now that his capital P
polls are shot and he said that after
Kaylee posted strong foreign policy
interview from Trump on Tucker Carlson
Trump excels when he talks policy yeah
right emphasizes his experience and
reminds Americans how safe our country
was on his watch this is just showing
you how sort of petty Trump is even
though this post from his former press
secretary is praising Trump I guess at
some point she praised sandus and Trump
really didn't like that so he's still
going after her then Trump continuing
and I could keep going all day but this
will be the last one Trump posting I
couldn't care less if Ron Des Sanctus
runs but the problem problem is the
capital B Bill he is about to sign which
allows him to run without resigning from
being Governor totally weakens capital E
election capital I Integrity in Florida
instead of getting tough and doing what
the people want same-day voting voter ID
proof of citizenship paper ballots hand
count this bill guts everything so this
is endless this all these messages I
just showed you are all from a few hour
period Trump is obsessed with the santus
it seems to be becoming an unhealthy
Obsession but the Strategic question
here of course is if DeSantis doesn't
announce
is it only going to get worse for him in
the sense that Trump is starting actual
campaign stuff he's doing events and he
even is going to do a town hall with CNN
let's talk about that next if you're
looking for the perfect Mother's Day
gift our sponsor Aura frames creates
incredible Ultra quality digital frames
for displaying pictures and videos you
can pre-load the frame with your
favorite memories pictures videos for
Mom to see when she opens it up you can
update it with unlimited photos and
videos from anywhere using the aura
frames app no fees ever no limits on
storage Aura frames was voted the number
one digital picture frame by wire cutter
the strategist and Wired Magazine my mom
loves the frame I gave her I also have
an aura frame in my house when we were
just traveling I was able to immediately
add pictures which pop up on my mom's
frame and I've noticed the photos look
like real Prince such high resolution
and the display is calibrated so that
you can not even tell it's a screen Aura
frames has an awesome Mother's Day deal
for my audience you'll get up to thirty
dollars off their best-selling Carver
map frame and free shipping go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description